-It's great to have you here
I love you as a comedian,
and it's been so fantastic
to see you in films recently
You're such a great actor.
And this is a film about,
you basically have a family,
and you have a secret family
-Yes.
I'm a dad with two families.
And in the two families --
They don't know
about each other,
so I'm a good guy...
[ Laughter ]
...who has two secret families
two wives, and --
But I have like two kids
in each of the families.
But in real life,
I have more children.
-Yeah. With just one family,
you have five kids.
-Yes.
-How do your five kids fee
when they see you in a movie
where you're like pulling of
with, like, very little
difficulty having two families
-Yes, well, you know, this fil
premiered at South by Southwest.
And they sent a link
to my wife to watch.
And she watched it
with my two older kids.
And my 13-year-old just,
at one point,
walked out and goes,
"Not watching this.
It might be true."
[ Laughter ]
So it's just --
I don't know what that say
about my relationship
with my family.
-Well, I will say,
touring stand-up comedian
is a good job for someone
with multiple families.
-Well, you know, I just --
I can't pull off being
a decent husband to one woman.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I know.
-How would someone do it
with two?
It just seems too hard.
-But with this film,
and with showing this film
at festivals, you have found out
this is more common
than you think.
-Yes. There --
At every screening we've had
there's been someone
in the audience that says,
"We had a neighbor,
or someone in our town, that
at the funeral, it was reveale
that there was two families.
-Wow.
-And I heard there was one guy
who had 6 families
and 30 children.
-Wow!
-Which is -- I mean, like...
No one caught on.
Like, how would you even
organize that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, all the children
must have the same name.
Like all the boys were Bob
-Right.
So you'd never screw it up
-I don't know
how you could do that.
-I got to say, if you can
make it to the funeral,
your funeral till they find out,
you tip your cap.
Like, you know,
you really are like, "Wow.
Well, you made it
the whole way."
-It's impressive.
-Yeah.
You are always on the road
and you talked
about this beforehand...
-Yes.
-...and you've since done it
You actually
did stand-up at a rodeo.
-I did.
-Yeah.
-I performed
at the San Antonio Rodeo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was my first rodeo.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, me wearing that ha
is not cultural appropriation.
[ Laughter ]
But -- I --
So, yeah, it was insane.
It's insane.
It's a huge event...
-Yeah.
-...these rodeos.
You know, the San Antonio Spur
have to go on the road
during the time of the rodeo
It's a big deal.
It's in the arena.
They bring in mud
and everything.
And there's a rodeo that occurs,
and then there's entertainment
Usually it's a country musician,
or, you know, like,
some Mexican musician
that's famous in the area.
And so they had comedy,
and it was just surreal,
because you're in the round,
and they kind of -- there'
some people seated in the area
and there was just
this guy yelling --
He's just going, "Whoo whoo!
the entire time.
And as comedians, you know like,
"Oh, maybe this guy's drunk,
but, like,
you also instinctively kno
that's just him.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what he does.
But it was strange to go after
these fantastic --
I mean,
they're amazing athletes.
-Right. Yeah.
-They literally have to
ride a bull or a horse
for like 4 seconds.
[ Laughter ]
And you watch it,
and you're like,
"I don't think I can do that
-Yeah.
-Like it's --
Like, I just --
The core strength
that would be required...
But, like, sometimes they ge
thrown off immediately,
and that's
their whole day of work.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's insane.
-All that training.
-There's very little sport
where you just get, like -
it might be one second.
-Right? And then,
if it reaches 4 seconds,
then someone with a horse
comes by and grabs you off
I'm like, "That's a good gig."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good get.
-Then you did a show.
So, you survived the rodeo
-Yes, I survived it.
-And then you're here
in New York, your hometown..
-Yes.
-...doing stand-up just at
like, a local club that
you perform at all the time.
-Stand Up NY,
which is a great club.
There's many great clubs
in the city.
-And you fell down?
-I fell.
I fell.
[ Laughter ]
You know -- you and Fred -
you know this,
because as a performer,
you go on stage,
and you want to, you know,
communicate a certain authority.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And falling on your face...
-This was on your way up.
-And by the way,
it was like one step.
[ Laughter ]
And, like, I asked afterwards,
I'm like,
"Has anyone else fallen?"
They're like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
"No one has ever fallen."
-And wait, Jim.
You're also telling me you don't
think you'd be good at rodeo
[ Laughter ]
-It's like this was my own
personal rodeo, I guess.
But it was --
People were very nice.
Because there's nothing
that communicates,
"This guy doesn't know
what he's doing
when he can't walk on stage.
I didn't even reach
the microphone.
And I was just like,
"I don't know
how I'm gonna respond to this.
But I think
I had worked out that day.
I work out like
once every four months.
[ Laughter ]
And so, like, my leg just wasn't
responding to me lifting.
[ Laughter ]
It was very embarrassing.
But luckily, we're showing i
on national television.
-I want to finish by askin
about your wife, Jeannie.
-Yes.
-We've talked about her a lo
over the last couple of visits
because she had a brain tumor.
-Yes.
-And she's recovered.
-Thank goodness.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you have --
You've spoken about it
in a very hilarious way,
in a very moving way on stage.
And now she has written a book
-Yeah.
I mean, it's amazing.
You know, this woman who is th
mother of five children
with a husband that's just gon
half the time.
And recovering
from a brain tumor,
and she starts these two
volunteer organizations.
And then she goes, "I'm gonn
write a book about it."
I'm like,
"Do you really want to do that?"
I mean, like,
I don't want to do anything.
She wrote this incredible book
'cause when she was going
through the experience,
she would google,
trying to find people
that had gone through
a similar experience.
So that was
the motivation behind it,
that she wanted to write thi
book, and it's an amazing book
You know, she's been
my writing partner for 20 years,
so she's very funny,
and it's an amazing book.
-I can't wait to read it,
and it's always such a pleasur
to have you here, Jim.